okay um yes and no die yet okay next up
I am a powerful woman
yeah magusis vinaya Jen Gina Wow
great job dude thank you so much all
right
um may I please have five latkes and a
cup of borscht okay uh Diet Emin yeah
fashionista Fiat latkes it'll
cool Portia holy dude how
are you so good at this I'm a Russian
Jew it's in my blood
it's it okay who can I trust
Kamui Emma good ever yet yes that is it
Wow okay no of course I'm not a dirty
Jew Ilana what the hell
poor sweet Abby yet kanye's Nia yeah Nia
yeah Nia Evita
oh my god I mean really good job but
yanks major yikes
okay here we go continuing on would you
like me to urinate on you strongman the
bhai wait you really think you're gonna
need that one okay if I'm going to
successfully infiltrate Russia I'm gonna
have to be able to speak the language to
seduce a cultural influencer plus you
know how to Peter's love their piss play
yeah I just want to be prepared for this
new sci-fi world we live in where the
rules change on the daily oh my god
speaking of which dude I just got my
knife for my go-bag cue it get out of
here buddy
hey sucker that's my satchel sure my go
bag is gonna be set okay next up so you
definitely hacked the election
you